la chanteuse d'opéra que j'ai entendu
applaudir nous voilà déjà dans le vif du
sujet je vous demander de prendre parti
n'ayez pas peur qu'ils votent pour
entendu une mouais qui votent pour
entendu une il y en a davantage et qui
votent pour les deux pas beaucoup merci
la règle française de l'accord du
participe passé ni reviendra alors à
chaque fois que je rencontre une
nouvelle personne quand j'annonce que je
suis correctrices au journal le monde
la première question qui vient c'est
mais ça fait des fautes
un journaliste et bah oui ça fait des
fautes un journaliste tout le monde fait
des fautes
les journalistes aussi alors les
journalistes d'un quotidien sont
d'autant plus excusable de faire des
fautes que bien souvent il travaille
très vite le journal le monde pour
donner cet exemple que je connais bien
boucle le matin à 10h30 quand un
journaliste est en train d'écrire son
papier à 9h30 sur le dernier tweet
nocturne de donald trump ou bien sûr ben
une première très attendue à l'opéra
bastille qui a eu lieu la veille rares
sont les journalistes qui vont sortir
leur bécherel pour vérifier si la
chanteuse que j'ai entendu applaudir ses
cris ont eu ou une la deuxième réflexion
qui vient quand je rencontre toujours
sept nouvelles personnes c'est là mais
vous êtes correctrices alors vous savez
tout est donc moi je chausse plus vous
parler ou en tout cas en tout cas pas
question je vous envoie un message alors
détrompez vous je ne suis pas
infaillible moi même un correcteur c'est
quoi un correcteur c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît bien la langue française certes
mais un correcteur n'est rien sans les
dictionnaires dont il est entouré en
permanence un correcteur vit entourée de
dictionnaires et de manuels qu'il ouvre
une cinquantaine de fois par jour
pourquoi
pourquoi pas parce qu'il ne sait pas
tout j'ai publié en 2010 est un livre
qui s'appelait au bonheur des fautes et
ce livre écrit par mois avec le plus
grand soin révisé par deux collègues
correctrices au monde et puis ensuite
corrigé par deux autres correctrices
rémunéré par l'éditeur vous remarquez au
passage que les correcteurs sont souvent
des correctrices aujourd'hui eh ben ce
livre comporte et encore 5 coquille
quand il est sorti en librairie
alors aujourd'hui il a été réimprimé un
certain nombre de fois donc maintenant
il est nickel
tant mieux mais c'est pour dire que ce
livre qui était sans doute l'un des
mieux corriger 2017 comportait encore
cinq co qui donc la perfection est
inatteignable tout ça c'est pour vous
mettre à l'aise pour vous dire qu'on n'a
jamais fini d'apprendre le français que
personne ne maîtrise le français à fond
et complètement et que d'ailleurs quand
on croit avoir fini d'apprendre
et ben l'académie française change les
règles ou bien celle usage de la rue qui
les bouleverse donc la perfection est
inatteignable la perfection est
inatteignable et bien tant mieux ça me
rappelle une phrase de freud à une jeune
femme qui lui demandait comment être une
bonne mère il avait répondu quelque
chose du genre
madame de toute façon quoique vous
fassiez vous vrai mal et moi en tant que
jeune maire à l'époque où j'ai entendu
cette phrase
eh ben j'ai trouvé ça très rassurant
très rassurant parce qu'à partir du
moment où il est impossible d'être
parfait et bien faisons de notre mieux
faisons notre possible
faisons le bas en tant que parent
faisons le aussi en tant qu'utilisateur
de notre langue maternelle le français
alors d'ailleurs ça va peut-être vous
semblez un tout petit peu paradoxal mais
si j'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelle au
bonheur des fautes c'est que les fautes
je les aime
alors d'abord j'adore les attraper ça
c'est mon sport favori
mais je les aime aussi parce que enfin
disons que celle que je trouve quand
même difficilement pardonnable ce sont
celles qui sont imprimés parce que les
photos imprimées sur le fait de
professionnels qui auraient dû se donner
les moyens on a bien vu qu'il était
impossible de ne faire aucune mais enfin
d'en faire le moins possible mais celle
que je pardonne complètement et que
souvent j'adore ce sont celles que
j'appelle les fautes commises en amateur
les fautes que vous écrivez sur vos
cartes postales dans les messages que
vous envoyez à vos copains les fautes
sont souvent drôles
j'ai corrigé n'y a pas très longtemps
dans le journal le monde
emmanuel macron tombé de son piédestal
qui était écrit en deux mots pied pays
ed comme mon pied
plus loin des apostrophes et ce talent
humour de correcteurs moi j'en ai
glousser toute une après-midi les fautes
sont souvent aussi touchante créative
les fautes des enfants pensée ou faute
des enfants ou des étrangers pour parler
des fautes des enfants quand mon fils
mon fils est là dans la salle est
beaucoup plus grand aujourd'hui mais mon
fils qui venait d'entrer au cp1 dimanche
matin était furax
il était 6 heures il venait d'apporter
une bouteille de jus d'orange un peu dur
à ouvrir et j'avais refusé de l'ouvrir
parce que je dormais et il a glissé sous
ma porte est un mot qui disait je t'aime
plus et c'était écrit
j e selon un théorème plus loin p à lui
est bien ce message était encore plus à
la fois évidemment encore plus drôle
mais en même temps un crève coeur encore
plus important parce que on se rend
compte qu'un enfant qui sait pas écrire
c'est s'est débrouillé pour passer son
message et puis c'est une oeuvre unique
alors un il a inventé la façon d'écrire
je t'aime plus et alors c'est encore
plus fort que s'il avait su l'écrire et
puis quand deux heures après en sortant
de ma chambre je trouve un autre mot qui
dit bonjour maman mais bonjour écrit bon
jour maman
eh ben c'est merveilleux parce qu on re
découvre le vrai sens du mot bonjour
qu'il est de vous souhaiter une bonne
journée
vraiment et puis d'ailleurs bonjour
évidemment que ça c'est d'abord écrit en
deux mots un c'est forcément l'origine
du mot bonjour
et puis même et puis même qui a
forcément eu une époque où il y avait
pas d'orthographe ce que vous y avez
pensé à ça avant jusqu'au xviie siècle
disons et la création de l'académie
française et même encore après parce que
la mission qui la mission qui lui avait
été confié par richelieu de créer une
grammaire un dictionnaire pour la langue
française n'est pas entré dans les
usages du public avant avant dans bien
des décennies
donc disons que jusqu au moins dix
huitième siècle chacun écrivait un peu
comme il le voulait j'en vois qui se
sont dit qu'ils sont nés trop tard
bon mais on va voir que justement
l'orthographe c'est beaucoup plus
relatif comme le croit souvent
alors la langue est complexe parce que
elle est pleine de notre histoire
mouton ou sapin nous viennent des
gaulois évidemment il ya des tas de
reste des invasions romaine on va voir
que la règle affreuse de l'accord du
participe passé date de françois 1er
donc le français évolue sans cesse
c'est le propre d'une langue vivante
c'est même pour cette raison qu'il ya de
nouveau dictionnaire chaque année qui
intègre de nouveaux mots de nouveaux
usages
la grosse révolution qui est en cours
actuellement et à laquelle on assiste
tous ça n'a pas pu vous échapper
c'est la féminisation des noms de
métiers et fonctions est ce qu'on doit
dire une sculpteuse ou une sculptrice
une hauteur un auteur ou une autre is
les dictionnaires choisissent leur camp
le petit robert a opté pour autrice mais
le larousse a opté pour une hauteur le
journal le parisien a opté pour autrice
tandis que le monde a choisi une hauteur
choisissez votre camp pour le moment
vous êtes libre ça sera peut-être pas le
cas pendant si longtemps que ça en tout
cas le résultat c'est la langue qui est
dans nos dictionnaires dans nos journaux
dans nos livres d'aujourd'hui et dont la
grammaire et l'orthographe ne sont pas
du tout aussi logique qu'ils essaient de
nous faire croire la plupart des livres
scolaires et c'est pourquoi les
exceptions sont souvent aussi nombreuses
que les cas qui se conforme à la règle
mais ces incongruités la de la langue
française ben justement moi elles sont
ma joie je trouve que ça fait partie de
ce qui fait que cette longue et
magnifique
et justement je voudrais en profiter
pour passer en revue avec vous quelques
chefs-d'oeuvre d'incohérence de la
langue française et vous allez voir
d'abord que la langue n'est pas gravé
dans le marbre et comment sont peut-être
par e1
l'exemple de ce pluriel compliquée d'un
mot que je viens de prononcer
chef-d'oeuvre un nom composé au pluriel
où est-ce qu'on me laisse chef-d'oeuvre
eh bien figurez vous que dans son
premier dictionnaire en 1694
l'académie a décidé que duraient deux
shf puis en oeuvre depuis vingt ans
après la sortie un nouveau dictionnaire
et elle a dit non pardon pas droit dont
n'ont en fait non en fait on va mettre
un seul ace oeuvre ok vingt ans après
leur sort un nouveau dictionnaire dinan
peuvent excusez nous mais en fait on va
mettre 2 1
un chef et puis oeuvre vingt ans après
elle recevra nos dictionnaires le s
revient oeuvre tout ça juste comme 1835
qui entérine chef-d'oeuvre avec un seul
ace mais hf cette fois et ça c'est comme
aujourd'hui pour votre information
mais jusqu au prochain changement vous
avez compris alors le ph de nénuphars a
connu à peu près les mêmes montagnes
russes
vous pouvez écrire un nénuphar depuis la
réforme de l'orthographe de 1990 avec un
f ou ph
mais nénuphars c'était écrit avec un f
dans tous les dictionnaires successives
de l'académie jusqu'en 1935 et puis en
1935 l'académie c'est du groupe
nénuphar nénuphars devrait s'écrire avec
un ph parce que nénuphars vient du grec
comme un fait acquis à la ph
on met un ph année nulle part sauf que
l'académie s'est trompé nénuphar vient
du persan en passant par l'arabe et donc
n'aurait jamais dû s'écrire avec un ph
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
le choix
donc voyez en fait l'orthographe c'est
pas les tables de la loi et les
dictionnaires ne font qu'entériner
lusage ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que la langue la langue
qu'on parle elle nous appartient à nous
à vous à moi à tous ceux qui l'utilisent
si on se met tous à faire la même faute
là aujourd'hui dans cette salle si on
décide de faire tous la même faute
et puis si on essaye d'être un peu
viraux de transmettre le virus autour de
nous et bien très vite cette faute n'en
sera plus une parce qu'elle va entrer
dans l'usagé donc dans les dictionnaires
blessé lui vingt ans peut-être ma
professeure de français en classe de
seconde
madame fournol je sais pas si elle est
encore en vie m'avait beaucoup vexé en
corrigeant le mot événements j'avais
écrit événements comme je viens de le
prononcer événement és puis peu accent
grave derrière comme l'écrivait et le
pronom comme le prononce la plupart des
français et comme la plupart du monde
des français l'écrivain et jt force
surprise et ford excès mais elle m'a
sorti son dictionnaire en disant non
regard des événements s'écrit événement
2 accent aigu je n'ai jamais oublié sauf
que depuis 1990 et bien figurez-vous
comme tout le monde faisait cette faute
vous pouvez l'écrire des deux façons
événements ou événements mais le plus
délicieux dans cette histoire c'est la
provenance de ce deuxième aux accents
aigus et denman qui embêtait tout le
monde et je les ai apprises d'un
courrier que m'a envoyé la grande
linguiste henriette walter et elle
m'explique
ne croyez pas que ce deuxième set
aberration ce deuxième et qui est une
aberration parce qu'il correspondait pas
la prononciation viennent d'une
réflexion intense de l'académie ou de
grammairien pas du tout il vient de coin
d'un manque momentanée de matériels
d'imprimerie
l'imprimeur du dictionnaire de
l'académie française au xviiie siècle
époque à laquelle on intégrait ses accès
et bien n'avait pas fait commandé
suffisamment de caractère de plomb avec
un accent grave voilà quand il lui
arrivait d'en manquer quand il y avait
plusieurs caractères dans une même page
il va lui arriver dans mon cas bouillot
remplacer sa part un accent aigu c'est
ce qui est arrivé dans ce même
dictionnaire homo mère d'ailleurs mère
maman alors maire a été corrigée dans le
dictionnaire suivants parce que quand
même c'était trop énorme mais événement
l'a oublié on l'a oublié jusqu'au xxème
siècle et voilà deux à trois siècles de
zéro en dictée à cause d'une erreur de
commandes de caractères d'imprimerie
donc voilà la langue française elle et
farceuse et les dictionnaires aussi la
règle des adjectifs de couleur n'est pas
mal non plus celle là pourquoi pourquoi
est ce qu'on écrit des yeux bleus avec
un et savent le mais des yeux marron
sans cesse à maron des jupes rouges avec
à l'esa rouge met des jupes orange sans
s à orange
pourquoi est ce qu'un prêt dans lequel
il ya des vaches noires et blanches
c'est pas exactement quand même près
qu'un prêt avec des vaches noir et blanc
alors les adjectifs de couleur
s'accordent en genre et en nombre avec
le nom auquel il se rapporte
comme tous les autres adjectifs dans la
plupart des cas sauf sauf les exceptions
les exceptions c'est les adjectifs de
couleurs qui sont basées sur des noms
des objets marron la couleur du marron
quand on dit des yeux marron c'est des
yeux de la couleur du marron la
châtaigne me marre ou des jupes orange
ne s'accorde pas parce que ce sont des
jupes de la couleur de l'oranje c'est
pour ça que des yeux verts prennent un s
avère mais des yeux émeraude pades am
road
l'autre cas où les adjectifs de couleur
composé ne s'accorde pas c'est quand ce
sont donc les adjectifs de couleur ne
s'accorde pas pardon c'est quand ils
sont composés
c'est pour ça qu'on écrit des yeux verts
avec un s avère mais des yeux vert foncé
sans s avère ni à foncer des cheveux
blonds
dk et sable on met des cheveux blonds
cendrés 100es sablon n'y as andré et
c'est pour la même raison que si dans un
pré il ya des vaches noires et blanches
alors ce sont des vaches tout noir et
des vaches toute blanche
si c'est des vaches bicolore alors elles
sont noirs et blancs adjectif de couleur
composé invariable alors évidemment la
pire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la règle des adjectifs de couleur
composé n'a pas encore été applaudi
c'est la première fois alors évidemment
la pire la pire de toutes les règles de
la langue française là c'est elle c'est
l'accord du participe passé non avec le
sujet pourquoi ce serait trop simple
avec le complément d'objet direct s'il
est placé avant
l'auxiliaire avoir d'où nous vient cette
règle d'un poète clément marot poète
officiel de françois 1er qui avait dit
on a ramené cette règle d'italie ils
trouvaient ça fort chic et il a réussi à
l'imposer en france alors elle plaît pas
à tout le monde un bescherelle qui n'est
pas le plus grand révolutionnaire dit
quand même que c'est la règle la plus
absurde de la langue française et
voltaire voltaire qui disait marot a
ramené deux choses d'italie la vérole et
l'accord du participe passé et je pense
que c'est le deuxième qui a fait le plus
de dégâts
en tout cas maintenant que nous avons
cette règle qui nous vient d'un poète et
avec un poète pour inventer ça et bien à
l'usom nous avec elle moi je vais vous
donner quelques exemples rigolos des
exemples que j'aime bien la mort de cet
homme que j'ai tant désiré désiré et
désiré et e
et voilà mais les deux sont possibles
1 selon qu'on a désiré l'homme masculin
où la mort féminin
si on a le désir et l'homme et sa mort
ça devient compliqué à écrire il faut
trouver une autre façon les verbes de
perception avec le participe passé c'est
une sacrée paire de manches
les verbes de perception c'est entendre
voir sentir etc
c'est là qu'on retrouve notre chanteuse
les verbes de perception s'accordent
uniquement si c'est le sujet du verbe à
l'infinitif qui accomplit l'action on va
comprendre
la chanteuse que j'ai entendu applaudir
alors en fait ceux qui ont gagné c'est
ceux qui ont voté les deux ayant n'avait
pas beaucoup dans la salle les deux
solutions sont elles sont justes mais
elle veut pas dire la même chose
la chanteuse que j'ai entendu applaudir
c'est pas elle qui accomplit l'action
donc invariable la chanteuse que j'ai
entendu eu à applaudir alors c'est la
chanteuse qui applaudit elle applaudit
peut-être son public ou ses musiciens
voilà si c'est elle qui accomplit
l'action on accorde c'est pour cette
raison que par exemple on écrira la
pièce de théâtre que j'ai vu jouer
v u c'est pas la pièce qui joue mais la
comédienne que j'ai vu jouer
v e c'est elle qui joue voilà c'est ça
la différence alors plus pervers plus
perdait encore que l'accord du participe
passé
c'est le cas de jean les gens gns un mot
si banal on croit le connaître en croit
le maîtrisais pas du tout pas du tout
d'abord ils se gênent pas pour devenir
féminin le mot gens quand il est
immédiatement précédé d'un adjectif
épithètes c'est pour ça qu'on dit de
bonnes gens de vieilles gens mais alors
encore plus troublant ils se gênent pas
pour changer de genre dans la même
phrase
c'est pour ça qu'on dirait ses vieilles
gens sont bons ces bonnes gens sont des
crétins et alors cette règle elle est
tellement tellement complexe beaucoup
plus complexe que ce que je viens de
vous dire là et donc je veux tu dois
vous avouer une chose j'ai jamais réussi
à la mémoriser complètement donc je vous
conseille une chose quand vous tombez
sur des gens
n'hésitez pas à sortir en gris mois pour
vérifier s'ils sont garçon ou fille
parce que selon il ya des virgules
ou pas etc ça change il ya un verre de
leonard cohen qui dit les failles
c'est par là que passe la lumière si on
croit tout savoir d'un napperon plus
rien si on apprend plus rien on n'est
pas loin d'être mort donc personne ne
sait tout sur la langue française et
c'est justement ça qui en fait un jeu
passionnant un jeu qu'on maîtrise
complètement si on n'a aucune chance de
te tromper mais à quoi bon jouer alors
je voudrais quand même évoqué aussi ces
moments où chercher la solution on a
ouverte à tous ses grimoires on la
trouve pas ou alors on n'a pas le temps
de chercher ça arrive souvent dans un
quotidien
on n'a pas le temps de chercher la bonne
solution et bien là il n'est pas
interdit d'être malin il est même
recommandé d'être roublard parfois je
voulais vous raconter une à témoignages
que j'ai entendu sur une radio un
étranger téléphonait pour partager son
truc il disait qu'il avait le plus grand
mal à retenir les genres en français
c'est vraiment un casse tête pour les
étrangers ça et donc il disait je sais
jamais si je doit commander un ou une
baguette à la boulangerie et disait mon
truc c'est un peu plus cher mais ça
marche je demande deux baguettes
il est pas interdit d'être malin et je
voulais aussi vous raconter ma blagues
favorites
c'est l'histoire d'un directeur de zoo
qui voudraient ajouter deux animaux à la
gamme d'aidés quadrupède qu'il offre à
l'admiration du public
il a choisi cette élégante et laon nord
américain qu'on appelle un orignal et
lui en faut 2 et alors il prend sa plus
belle plume et ils sont plus beau
clavier est il écrit à son collègue
canadien chers collègues
accepteriez vous de me vendre deux
orignaux opus 10 et peut-être pas ça il
efface tout et on recommence
chers collègues accepteriez vous de me
vendre 2 orignal avec un rsa orignal et
il a encore des doutes qu'il a une idée
il recommence tout chers collègues
accepteriez vous de me vendre un orignal
a parce que tom tant que vous y êtes
mais dément donc un deuxième donc voilà
vous connaissez pas une orthographe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous ne connaissez pas une orthographe
rien ne vous interdit d'être malin et
puis d'ailleurs le directeur de zoo a de
bonnes raisons de douter parce qu'en
fait le larousse et le robert disent
qu'est ce qu'ils disent ils disent les
orignaux tandis que le larousse point fr
penche pour orignal avec un s donc voila
mon conseil si jamais vous voulez en
acheter commander des élans merci
[Applaudissements]